c'est un colosse expérimenté à la barbe
légèrement grisonnante l'arrivée du père
noël avant l'heure à 39 ans georgi
joseph les deux retours en val de loire
un beau cadeau pour tour cette fois avec
plus de 320 matches en proa et 117 en
pro b
georgi joseph l'état joueurs référencés
en lnb passé par orléans villeurbanne
bourg-en-bresse monaco peau le pivot
parisien a déjà été champion de france 2
3 et vainqueur de la leader ce cap on
peut en continu
j'aime le sport j'aime ma technique et
physique soit sur lui parce que j'aime
le talentueux compétiteurs donc quoi
qu'il arrive quand on quand on dit quand
on prend de l'âge et qu'on voit les
jeunes pousses venir grappiller des
minutes ni revault vous connais un petit
peu ou secouer ça fait plaisir je
connaissais le petit combo des
tout-petits lorsqu'elle avait 3 4 ans
evènement je joue avec lui on se
rentrent dedans
les compétiteurs georgi joseph remplace
amadou sidibé victime d'une entorse au
genou et absent six semaines pierre
tavano va pouvoir compter sur cet
intérieur réputé pour sa dureté au sens
de l'engagement et sa science du jeu on
a eu de la chance de tomber sur georgi
joseph qui étaient étaient libres qui
venait de terminer sa pige à strasbourg
un club de betclic élite donc on va en
profiter
on est content parce qu'il a donné son
accord et maintenant il nous a montré
que son premier match il avait toutes
les qualités requises pour nous apporter
beaucoup sur cette pige après une
défaite à domicile face à chalon sur
saône vendredi dernier tout resterait
dans le groupe de tête en cas de
victoire ce soir à aix maurienne avant
de recevoir qu'un frère dans huit jours